welsh utopian in 1817 who came up with
eight hours work eight hours leisure um
and eight hours of sleep and and that
was it it's as random as that
so it's not like it was predetermined by
some people like yes this is exactly how
we should be working so you know we can
make new rules up
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
hello hello welcome to another episode
of 20 minute leaders we're going to be
talking to a really interesting leader
today sophie wade the founder of flex
cell network llc
sophie is a work futurist international
keynote speaker author and authority on
fortune of work issues
she is the host of the widely popular
transforming work podcast and over 450
000 learners have taken her four
linkedin courses which cover empathy
future of work skills and generation z
delphi is the founder and workforce
innovation specialist at flex cell
network a future of work consultancy
sophie's executive advisory work in
transformative workshops help companies
adapt and update their work environments
and attract engage and retain their
multi-generational and distributed
talent she helps corporations maximize
the benefits and minimize the disruption
in their transition to talent-focused
digitalized work environments
[Music]
the site idea of workforce innovation
you know as a concept is this you know
we have we've been having
different uh
different types of work for for some for
small number of years some for thousands
of years where are we in the timeline of
how long have we been dealing with a
question of you know workforce
innovation and how do people work in the
world
uh
i love the question
that's a new one so what i would say is
there is no set way of working and i
have lived and worked in five different
countries
so i am very uh aware that there is no
sort of set way of working and people
different countries have very different
approaches and attitudes and and to work
and work culture
and that has a huge impact on what the
possibilities that they see for the
future and how they're adapting to the
new sort of work frame so i think you
know we have like the eight the the the
40 hour work week is something that came
up it was a
a welsh utopian in 1817 who came up with
eight hours work eight hours leisure um
and eight hours of sleep and and that
was it it's as random as that
so it's not like it was predetermined by
some people like yes this is exactly how
we should be working so you know we can
make new rules up and people do in all
kinds of situations so it has always
been evolving and it's been evolving
based on the technology that we have of
the day whether it's the you know
working in huge um you know factory
lines then we get you know more
personalized uh more sort of more mobile
ways of working and obviously are the
way we adapt
to those new technologies that are
giving us more options
but it's really controversial right i
mean anybody who tries to challenge
the notion of the eight hour
work day or or any any shift in the
balance that that we're used to all of a
sudden it feels as if you're you're
challenging the whole paradigm of what
it means to be human i mean it's really
a daunting task why is it why is it so
dramatic changing you know within a
company the thought process of
how do we actually need to balance on
what are the company's needs not every
company needs eight hours a day in terms
of effectiveness right
absolutely
the i think
you know we are human beings we're
creatures of habit we're comfortable
that way
and so changing something which has
worked for a long time or appears to
have worked and you know the very nature
of work has changed it is less
predictable it is less linear and static
so we are actually needing to adapt how
we're working
period
um but it did sort of it was something
that we got into the routine of and it
worked for though for the what we know
the data that we knew at the time we
also you know think that thought that if
we paid people that would be enough we
now understand that it's not enough that
they just go through the motions didn't
necessarily engage and now work is much
more complicated we're dealing much more
complicated issues we're having to work
in teams much more you know it has
raised the bar in terms of how we need
to engage so that's when we also need to
change how we're sort of thinking about
work in order to deal with the the the
construct and the and the issues and the
problems of today so you know i think
the controversy is really about um
changing habits and that's where i see
the pandemic has actually been sort of
useful in in
being so disruptive that we can we are
now sort of out of our routines
and and really which has dislodged us
from
the
routines that were actually really we
were straining against for a long time
because the future of work has been
coming the new ways of working um and
the new ways of doing business and
operating with more flexibility
have been adapting over the last couple
of decades at least and so you know that
sort of helped us think differently
about how we need to approach work
right and and this idea of where
you know the where where the priorities
also for
this even thought process right so we're
running through these thought
experiments
where and and we need to have you know
at the end a central figure that we're
trying to optimize for
and and i think that's it's also a
pretty controversial question are we
optimizing for company value are we
optimizing for um you know a problem
that we're trying to solve as as a as a
large group or are we solving for the
human so where are we
in this in this space
for the business and the human not not
for a central figure that we can you
know there is no uh you know all
one size fits all you know we need to
dispel that idea we don't we have gone
down to up trying to optimize for the
customer the individual customer
somebody we can recognize on the street
and we need to have the same mindset so
for me it's the priority is the mindset
which is open-minded inclusive it's
really trying to recognize each person
as an individual because if we're going
to try and you to try and attract and
convert and um and you know take care of
a customer who is in an individual
person we need to do that the same thing
for the employee we can't you know it's
these days we cannot have very different
approaches for external and internal
relationships and treatment
so that that becomes more probably more
challenging um in terms of trying to
adapt for each person individually but
it is certainly possible people have
been you know
do recognize that
you know you know mark is really you
know asleep at nine o'clock in the
morning so let's just you know delay the
the monday morning meeting a little bit
later so he can actually
bring his you know bring his
intelligence and all that he has to work
because otherwise we're just not going
to get as much out of him that serves
the that serves the business and it
serves him too so there are many
different ways that we have adapting
this is just taking that
another step further
because as i say the
the
what the needs of the business are it's
more demanding our customers are
changing their behaviors based on the
pandemic based on the the changing
needs of of you know as we're
integrating more technologies it's
changing how our customers are reacting
you know our competitors integrate
different technologies that changes our
customer behaviors and we're needing to
make upgrades or our customers are
telling us what what they like what they
don't like more than we necessarily want
and we're having to to adapt and that
means that we need to be responsive um
and we need to give our employees the
flexibility to be responsive too
and and how does empathy tie into all of
this
empathy
in the way i look at it is just about
human understanding it's if i if i'm
going to work effectively with you i
need to understand more about you i need
to you know the the i mean i can see you
and i can say like okay is that face is
that concentrating is that being
distracted he's got some you know you
know video on the side that he's
actually looking at which is amusing him
i don't know but i need the more i
understand you the more i can find out
about you the more i can better manage
you or you can better manage me when we
understand each other so empathy is
really it's trying to understand who you
are how you see the world and then
connect with your experience and then i
can manage you better or we can work
together better as a team
so if we're actually looking at you know
the workplace and team management and
you know whether it's mid-level
management top-level management or just
colleagues
what are different things that we might
that are not so trivial when it comes to
working with empathy in the workplace
when you're getting started i mean we
all have a lot of empathy in our
personal lives how you know when we're
dealing with our parents when we're
dealing with our kids and we're dealing
with our friends we you know we
we use it a lot we just haven't in the
workplace so when we're thinking about
bringing that empathy in it's really
about paying a lot more attention and to
begin with it will take time it will
feel a little bit contrived it will take
more effort but when we do it and we
actually
make empathy habits and so in my book
it's really about establishing new
empathy habits then it just becomes how
you're working it's listening more it's
kind of like do i understand what he's
actually saying is michael do i really
understand that and then restating it so
what i understand is what i understand
what you said and that both validates
what you've said shows that i'm
interested in understanding i don't have
to agree with it but i'm trying to
understand and i'm showing i'm trying to
understand your perspective so there are
lots of little things so it's about
having
you know more sort of deeper and more
thoughtful relationships
and that also it doesn't mean we have to
be super friends but we when i
understand you better we're going to
have also have a lot less conflict
because we have better we have more
willingness to try and get to the same
page or try and sort of understand the
information that's informing your
opinion versus mine so it does take you
know some more efforts more
attentiveness you know trying to read
the features the body language um and
and you know stepping back from our
judgments judgments when we're
particularly when we're working at the
pace we are these days stepping back
kind of going okay i'm assuming my
assumption about what he meant was this
but did he really because if i if i send
off a sort of snippy email because i
misinterpret you then we you know like
we're just wasting a whole bunch of time
and energy and bad bad blood until we
can sort of work it out oh
he didn't actually mean that okay fine
so it's really just taking you know to
begin with taking a few more steps being
a bit more thoughtful um and uh and also
we do actually need to understand
ourselves more before we can understand
others and that that can take a little
bit more time i agree
you said something interesting that i
that i want to dive dig a little bit
deeper sure
it was you were talking about how you
know we have empathy it seems that we
have empathy in our daily lives and all
of a sudden you know we're coming to
work and we sometimes forget to
to employ those same habits
in the workplace and i'm trying to think
why i'm trying to think why did we
naturally
make this distinction that you know when
we're at work then we're a certain way
and then we come home is it you know is
it because that there's different
incentives yes in work that that some
are perhaps contrary to empathic
behavior like getting ahead and maybe
there's limited resources and whoever
you know is the strongest survives i
mean what what is it about the workplace
that lends itself
to create conflicts for humans to be
more empathetic to each other
so uh
so first of all i would say that when
you introduce money into the situation
it changes it uh so one of the most
impactful
leadership roles i had was leading a
non-profit organization
i was the president of the
the new york chapter of the national
association of women women business
owners and when you're trying to
motivate and manage and lead people
without there being any money you have
to do it on a very very different basis
you know you're connecting people with
purpose you're trying to create the kind
of culture you're trying to sort of
understand people's individual
motivations and trying to sort of tap
into those so you're doing all those
type of things which are really trying
to understand who that person is and so
that's a very beneficial so i think
money changes that
money changes or certainly was
the believed to be this sufficient
incentive and we now have you know reams
of data that prove that that's not the
case and and aligning people with their
skills and strengths and and motivating
people different ways and you know
connecting people with purpose those are
all things that we now know help people
um
sort of work you know more effectively
but also align people and help people um
you know create an atmosphere and
environment which isn't as transactional
because it's motivated um very
differently i think the the other thing
that there is some research on which is
as
you
rise as a leader
there is a balance about how easy it is
to be empathetic
um i think partly because of you know
the role that you're in you're trying to
get things done
i i do think this is
this is still part of the way that we
have been working the cultures that
we've been working in or not paying
attention to developing the kind of
cultures and trust-based relationships
that allow people to lead in a very
different way which is more about
empathy than ego
and when we can do that we can lead in a
very different way which doesn't have to
mean that leaders uh you know leaders
can be connecting with people and and
sort of helping them
you know do their do their best work um
and that's my job as a leader now is to
help you do your best work not be
telling you what to do and thinking i
have all the answers and do we have
proof that this is actually beneficial
not just for the human
which obviously it is because it means
that we enjoy work more we feel more
fulfilled we come back home and it's
just this cycle that we that we're in
but do we know that this is actually
also beneficial for businesses is there
an incentive
from a business point of view to work on
something that is less
tangible and less a
less qualitative like empathy
it is hard to measure empathy directly
however if you're looking at if you sort
of look at engagement and you sort of
think about if i understand you better
i can help
you
align with your work and help you get
engaged in your work um there are
certainly data from gallup for example
in terms of the increased profits the
increased revenues that one finds that
when you have helped engage employees
whether it's aligning with their skills
and you know helping them connect with
the purpose and and really
be sort of understanding what their
contributions are on a daily basis and
so in all of these areas
you can find that you know empathy is
really about how i'm going to do that
how as a manager i'm going to help you
connect with your work and and also tap
into like if there's if there's
something going on if i sort of realize
i recognize that you're sort of a bit
off i either buy your phone you know
voice tone or or you you know you
weren't as fast to get back to me you
know something's going on empathy is
going to help me
recognize is there is there something
going on at work is it a problem with a
project or is it you know a family
situation just those little things are
going to help
you know
uh any situation not be prolonged we can
address it quickly and then you can sort
of get back you know on the job and be
doing your best work again obviously
that's going to to uh have better
lead to better outcomes because you we
we're able to to solve any problem or
deal deal with an issue you know early
on and before things get off track right
okay so so looking tangibly i'm you know
in my day-to-day what are things that i
can leave here
and effectively do
that i may not be doing now that that
will
you know
make help me become more empathetic
to
others around me whether it's colleagues
or managers or or people that are
working above or below me what what are
some actual things i can do
okay great so so as i said my book has
lots of empathy habits in there are a
number of them whether you're in sales
or or or a leader or in teams a couple
of the things i would say is uh starting
uh meetings with a small period which is
just about sort of connecting a
relationship-wise particularly important
if you're uh you know you're connecting
remotely because you're really having to
re-establish that we know we know each
other so we can actually have the basis
of a productive conversation convert and
then and then talking about some of the
things that that you you do have sort of
common ground and you'll share
particular interests because that sort
of establishes oh you know yes my
michael's kind of like oh okay yeah
sophie i know her and so that's one
thing that actually is important both
for building the relationship making
sure that we're connecting and then
particularly if there's a difficult
issue that we have to deal with that i'm
showing you particularly at the big at
the beginning i'm showing you some areas
where we are on the same page in terms
of you know this particular area or
topic
so that so that we can start on the on
the sort of with a positive outlook and
then we can just you know have a better
understanding of how we're going to
explore some of the more challenging
areas of that particular subject
there are also ways
during meetings where you can be
listening there um you can be listening
you can be showing that you're listening
you can restate
um you know what the person has said
that also gives the person a chance to
kind of go well is that exactly what i
meant or she hasn't necessarily
understood what i said let me just try
and say it differently and so
when that actually sort of helps give
more details gives more understanding
more clarity and it also shows that you
you recognize that i'm trying to
understand you in follow-up to a meeting
you know you know having a conclusion so
they're all agreed we all know it's very
very clear just having a lot more
clarity about what's going on is being
empathetic because it means that we both
know exactly what the meeting was about
how we concluded what the next steps are
and we can afford i'd also say being
empathetic is i have a huge peeve about
meetings we need to be more effective
with our meetings we need to be you know
judicious about whether we need to have
a meeting or not not waste people's
times just talking to organization they
record every single meeting and they're
what they they recorded and they put
notes as well that means in those those
recordings are
searchable by keyword search which means
i don't have to include you and you
don't have to feel excluded if i don't
because you know that you can get on
with with you can choose to be in the
meeting or not you can get on with your
work and then afterwards you can like
search it see if there was anything that
was relevant for you quickly have a look
at it and be productive like that's
being empathetic because i'm being i am
being i'm valuing your time and
recognizing your your your time is
precious and you have a lot of other
things to do so um i think there are
those are some key there's like a lot of
things about being thoughtful about the
other person and what they're going
through and how they're actually
achieving their business outcomes and
you know and then we're working working
together being you know being responsive
to each other and sort of really really
watching and listening and learning and
asking more questions and what i what i
particularly enjoy that i'll also take
with me is this idea of clarity as being
more empathetic you know being clear
which is not it's not an intuitively
right association with empathy this idea
that if we manage to to create an
objective clear conclusion as to what
happened here and we can agree on the
situation we agree on the outcome and we
agree on what was decided that in effect
is being empathetic and and and
obviously you know the the
other things were also fascinating just
like and something that i firmly believe
in this idea of being very judicious
with the meetings and which meetings
were we actually needed which ones we
don't time is the most important
resource but but this idea of reaching a
clear conclusion that we agree on of
avoiding the pitfalls of later on
misinterpretations and and
and such it's it's fascinating and then
sophia i really want to thank you for
for your time and for your uh effort in
these 20 minutes it's it's fascinating
and and you know i think this is it's
such an interesting question and you
know i started the conversation with
asking you know where where is work
innovation today and and how long has it
been and honestly i don't remember too
many people
talking about this even 10 years ago
right i mean and it feels like this is
such a new concept that we're even
challenging this notion of
how are we working are we working the
right way are we communicating the right
way
we've never i don't think we've ever
really addressed the how and now now
everything's been thrown up in the air
now we have so many more options we
actually need to be thoughtful and
design how we work and we actually don't
even know how we each one of us works
best we found out more over the last two
years so when we when we look at the how
we design it we look at the workflow and
that's how it all ought to do with
technology
if we don't do it carefully we don't
clarify these things it's going to be
even more messy than it needs to be so i
think you know ultimately we'll come out
at a great place we'll be able to you
know focus on each other individually
and sort of work to do our best work in
the meantime it's going to be a it's
going to be a little bit messy but we're
going to get it thank you very very much
and this was wonderful
and stay safe stay healthy and i'm
looking forward to checking out empathy
awards by myself thank you
[Music]